[Music]
welcome back to new rock stars loki is
unleashing the god of mischief to run
amok throughout the mcu history and
possibly
rewrite the whole timeline from scratch
are we about to see
a true time heist to which endgame was
merely
the averager i'm eric voss this is rogue
theory going rogue with me today
is marina mastros hey marina hi eric
i love the way you said that at the end
you turned into a puppet i
i i accidentally was uh channeling uh
moira rose because i've been watching
uh i really love her david guy says
justin
we also got with us off screen and
increasingly on screen producer zach
huddleston
happy new year happy new year
uh i um never seen a shit's creek
episode so
uh i can only infer what you're
referencing you're missing out
it's so good we're also thrilled to
welcome to the show tv writer
comedian and host of the we have to stop
talking tmnt on cbb podcast
sean distant hey man hello i'm so i'm so
excited to be here
such a fan of new rock stars i'm here
with i'm with the holy trinity minus
philip molina yeah i'm very excited to
be here i'm with grogu grogu do you like
shit's creek
wake up oh my gosh
rogue's been misbehaving but i guess
groggy doesn't like shit's creek hi guys
i'm so excited to be here
grogu is a parks and rec guy he loves
he loves the mugging to camera yeah
i'm so happy to have the three of you
with me as this
is the first episode of the new season
of rogue theory it's new year new season
uh and as we start season two we are
gonna take some inspiration from the god
of mischief
and mix it up a little today we are
gonna burn down
the stiff formalities of the past and
just engage in the nerdy group rabbit
hole plunge that
we would be having before and after the
cameras roll
but as i do i'm pissed i i still want
sparkle bucks do you understand
well oh good of you to mention that sean
because
as i do in every other conversation in
my life i will still be mentally
awarding and subtraction
[Laughter]
yeah it's just a conversation but there
will be winners and losers yes eric will
be looking down and marking a sheet and
then looking back
i always carry around a little notepad
of graph paper everywhere i go
and i'm just writing numbers down people
are like oh he's a charmer
let's invite him
good easter egg marina
well as we all look ahead to this new
year in marvel
loki really seems like the bonkers rule
breaker that is custom designed for
us i am still trying to wrap my head
around this recent trailer guys
beyond the uh real world mysteries that
the show is trying
to tie into like tv cooper there are
confirmed shots of
loki replaying the avengers 2012 events
not just in the footage from endgame
he is at the back at the top of stark
tower ready to roll
and i feel like you know this is uh
spring 2019 again we're back analyzing
end game trailers for clues about how
the time heist would work
but this time the time heist is being
run not by a group of lame boy scouts
trying to keep the timeline intact
but by a madman who wants to burn
everything down
so i won what happens when your time
heist goes
bad baby right yes let's all dive into
this together how is loki going to
rewrite the mcu timeline in ways that
end game stops short of is this going to
be
like an elseworld mcu darkest timeline
that is unaffected from the main
timeline
is loki going to undo any of the
elements of the endgame time heist
itself
uh since loki's arrest by the tva occurs
right after his escape from the 2012
battle of new york
let's let's start there how how do you
guys think loki might do things
differently this time so it's
interesting like i see
in the trailer he has the scepter and
he's looking in that mirror
yeah and it looks like he's sort of like
back in his and i don't know how time
travel is working if it's gonna be like
loki himself is traveling or if his mind
is traveling inside i thought you were
gonna sean i thought you were gonna be
like
i don't know how time travel works
exactly
like a lot of my notes are okay some of
this could be conflicting
inverted mobius strip
according to my math i i do think that
that
sort of would be the first place he goes
because like his first memory is like
i just lost the battle of new york and
what i was thinking about the other
day was like his sort of rivalry with
the hulk
almost and like how through like
ragnarok he was like i am like i hate
that guy and like
he has this thing i mean he just
literally was smashed by the hulk
he gets the the uh tesseract and now
he's like
master of time travel and part of what i
think he might
try is after failing to right the wrongs
at the battle of new york maybe he goes
back
further and they revisit the hulk's
origin story which we don't actually
have a good version of in marvel
right they skip over it i kind of yeah
in the ed norton movie
i i was like what if you do the thing of
like what if you kill hitler before he's
born what if he tries to stop
banner from becoming hulk
and that like led me down this because
because in the trailer there's that
huge like uh he's in central park or
something and it looks like avengers
tower is destroyed right yeah
and i was like what if instead of the
chatari destroying new york
what if thaddeus ross red hulk
is created instead of the hulk and then
goes through the timeline as an avenger
with the avengers as red hulk
and and then like after ultron
instead of them like being like hey you
know uh
instead of like natasha being like go be
a hero he doesn't have that so like
after ultron
you get iron man be like go you have to
be you got to get off of earth and you
get the like planet hulk red
like like planet hulk like world breaker
hulk story
yeah and in my head i was like is that
red hulk returned from sakhar to destroy
earth because he was banished after
ultron and i was like that's what's cool
about this show
is they could do all of that in like
here's what would happen if you did that
and it's just a series of clips
and you don't have to do like a full
episode or an arc with it it's like
if you stop banner from being created
then you unleash the red hulk on
everyone
and like i think what's cool about the
show is you can have these really crazy
things happen
while like luke wilson or whatever owen
wilson is just like showing him
on a screen what would happen yeah he
just shows it to him and he's like well
i think that's probably not a good idea
well you know bad bod
wow that's so new york's destroyed wow
because i think if you're if you're
playing in the tva you got to play in
these worlds of like if you do this
thing
then a thousand other bad things can
happen yeah yeah for sure i know
sean you bring up a good point i mean i
kind of overlooked this in the loki
trailer but the way
new york was destroyed in that shot is
super weird that doesn't look like a
cha-cha
yeah there's no there's no chitari like
big warships there's no evidence of that
to me i was like is this like red hulk
slapping his hands together and like oh
destroying all of new york yeah and
i can see you and honestly i know that
like you love
red hulk and i wanted to bring you a
sort of way to get
thaddeus ross in there because you may
not get a real red hulk
but if you can get this like alternate
timeline peek at what it would be like
and then throw red hulk in the like
planet hulk story or something he comes
back with like corg and meek and
destroys earth
yeah yeah that would be that would be
the craziest thing you could see in a
loki show i think
i love that and i feel like that might
you know tie into
why loki needs to run for president i
mean we see that
looking for president thing where he's
like well look yeah ross was gonna be
secretary of state
near the white house like now i need to
restore the political order
in this country it's in a world with no
sokovia accords and no thaddeus
like like i think that that's really
interesting because i was wondering to
him like how does he run for president
what exactly is it yes i i love that too
if that's why he has to run for
president because like we're assuming
you know like the the power levels of
loki as a character kind of
very movie to movie or whatever but
probably here he's gonna be like
a relatively depowered version i assume
as he's hopping around and maybe not
like
full god mode and he's kind of just
using his powers of like persuasion
and kind of general like you know mental
manipulation
which i mean how great for politics
right like uh kind of worm tongue in his
way into uh
into national politics is like such a
fun move for that character
i mean if like if things are gonna be
different in this timeline you guys can
tell me if this is stupid or not just
start yelling
the word stupid at me
it's like if let's say he goes back and
changes it
or let's say in this version um they
lose the battle of new york
right you could make an argument that
they're
that the planet aligns and there aren't
any nations anymore
because they're like oh we have this
outer planetary like
why the [ __ ] would we have countries
when we have aliens
so what if he's like not running for
president of the united states it's like
there's a president of the world now
so he's like starship troopers there's
just like the federation
yeah and he's like i want to run for
that which is like because
because like why would loki want to be
the president the united states is like
too small
for him but being president of the world
is he'd be like
he didn't make a button for that that's
also i love that too that's basically
co-opting like the watchmen plot
yeah you know there's like an alien
unites humanity
which hey marvel does not own the
watchman right so it's a nice way for
them to
yeah yeah it would be one of those
really interesting things like to see
he won the battle of new york and then
there was a utopia like
instead of the end game story happening
it's like
well actually after that iron man did
kind of calm down with a lot of
futurism yeah like yeah really
well what i love is like uh so there's
like two sides to this right there's
what his mission is under the tva the
tva has arrested him it looks like they
need him for something and then there's
like what loki will probably do to
subvert that mission
right if you think like paul walker and
the fast and the furious
he had a mission he subverted the
mission and then like basic storytelling
rules are
his attempt to subvert it is gonna get
foiled in some way that blows up in his
face
so like i'm dying to know what each of
these three things are
like what's the initial goal the side
goal
and then the the goal that like he
presents itself
well i i have an idea on on that note
eric right
i think it's interesting that the
tesseract is the space stone
not the time stone yeah right like so
it's like in theory this is not
it's not a time travelly infinity stone
right it's supposed to be able to like
go different places
or possibly write like different
multiverse
realities right and so what if he's not
actually traveling back and forth in
time
but just like hopping between these like
different realities
and like the tva has like a to-do list
of like you gotta head to this reality
and fix this thing and then like head
over home that's fine this went wrong or
whatever
it's like a week-to-week episodic like
we got a problem in this reality logan
it's quantum leap yeah like only only by
like you know whatever
checking the 19 boxes or however many
episodes yeah
can will they drop him back into his his
reality
yeah yeah the question of why it's the
space stone is so interesting to me and
i and like what i sort of was thinking
was possibly
maybe the tva pulls loki out of a
timeline
you know like he created a branch
timeline when he moved off with the
space stone
so instead of like giving him the space
stone to go like
conquer earth with the space stone the
tva pulls him out of the timeline being
like look
you're kind of a vestigial thing of the
avengers meddling with time
but we need that to happen like we need
end game to happen so
what if we pulled you out of the
timeline and you just worked for us
you became a tva agent and in doing so
going on these missions with them
learning the secrets of time travel loki
says hey you know what i'm
loki so i'm gonna like actually take
this elevator where i want
and i think that's where you see him in
that like weird arcade where it's like
okay i've i've gotten
it's it's almost like he's gone a little
too far with the power that he's been
given by the tva you know
yeah um and in that way he creates a
huge mess that i guess he has to clean
up by the end of the series or something
yeah what i'm hoping is like uh maybe
his
mission the tva is like those avengers
here friends with these like they're not
my friends and they're like yeah
okay uh they're they swear to the
timeline
time heist of theirs they weren't
supposed to do that thanos was supposed
to win
so we need you to go in there because
you were there and
undo their little time heist you're
gonna see two different
tony starks one's gonna be dressed up in
swat gear we need you to take them out
you know there's gonna be two caps just
go with it and then loki gets there and
he's like no
i would love because here's i mean you
guys might know somebody i loved
avengers in game i think the time heist
could have been so much more
it could have been crazier and really
they just kind of dealt uh with it like
an a to b
kind of thing uh and i think loki could
be like
the layer under the layer of madness
there
and then what you said sean i think he
discovers his own kind of plan he's like
i could be president i could do whatever
the hell i want
but like obviously there is some kind of
insanity with like
sophia demartino's character as like a
lady loki like
maybe that's his doppelganger that he
has to kind of try to stop you know to
set the universe back in order yeah like
he instead of having to do
episodic stuff right of like in this one
you have to go to this western town and
the old west or whatever and like save a
saloon
you have to save it by the way not
not just like do oh yeah yeah save it
uh like yeah he has an overarching
mission as opposed to like
singular things and he could spend an
entire season chasing
himself right himself in female form or
whatever
yeah and and i think with an overarching
mission
it gives him the like i'm gonna go do my
side thing which is really where the
chaos of the show
is like when he's it's i've been
thinking about that d.b cooper thing so
much because i'm like
is he being db cooper because he knew
from history that he existed
and he's taking his place or
did dv cooper always happen as loki like
there's so many
weird chaotic things i like i love the
idea of like
because he's he's like a time cop or
whatever basically right and so they
have to be super
he's the new man
all day long um but because of that
right these time cops are extra
concerned with
um not screwing anything up not leaving
a timeline like worse than you
you then you found it like no kind of
butterfly effect type stuff yeah so like
what if he always has to arrive as
somebody who's going to disappear
because then it will make sense when he
just zaps away
[Applause]
like he has to be amelia earhart or db
cooper
or jimmy
somewhere i was like it'd be fun if
amelia earhart was a tva agent or
something like it could be really that's
really interesting that's so cool
oh no he was jack the ripper yeah
cause like when you think about it like
they don't want like the stewardess
that's on that plane
that he's on right when he disappears
into the ether because the tesseract let
him zap away
yeah that woman's life is gonna be
ruined right she's gonna be like
unless it can be explained like oh he
had a parachute he jumped out and nobody
ever saw him ever again right yeah
um zach oh that's so cool this whole
idea of like
making it uh this always happened
version of time travel where it's like
well obviously in our existence amelia
earhart
db cooper those are mysteries uh but
like to use loki to plug in each of
those holes
yeah that's so cool i mean it would
completely contradict the branch theory
of time travel that end game tried to do
but it could also be a way it could be a
way for loki to hide his tracks
like if he assumes the identity of
someone who goes missing
how much can he really affect the
timeline yeah
so it's like whatever he does right
before the db cooper thing might have
been the actual important mission he was
on
right and then the db cooper thing is
like a cover to disappear
oh my goodness um he just like pushes
the real db cooper out of the plane and
he's like sorry buddy
you know eric and you also mentioned the
like avengers that avengers tower
like sequence i feel like it could be
one of those like russian doll things
where you see like
five versions of it where it's loki
trying to figure out new
ways to to like subvert what happened
and ultimately i don't know how it would
work but it'd be a really interesting
cathartic
ending if like loki the only way loki
realizes that like
things can go back to normal as if this
loki doesn't exist
so he goes to like the hulk or the iron
man and he's like he's like don't have
him take the stairs
yeah trust me like something bad will
happen and that's like the final like
sort of domino that he pushes to make it
so that he never existed and disappears
or something oh that's cool
well yeah on on that same note sean like
i i love that idea
and that feels like i one thing i like
about when this series is set for this
character right
is that this is like it's not like a
prequel
or a sequel it's like a weird middle
class
yeah yeah because like we this is
technically the loki who's going to be
in this series
is still the like villain loki right
from the first avengers in the first
thor movie
and he hasn't kind of had this nice
character arc that we got in like
ragnarok and like
uh infinity war whatever right where
he's kind of like becoming more like
anti-hero
like nuanced guy who kind of cares about
his brother or whatever and so like this
show could also be like the bridge
between those two
guys right we could get to see him like
learn a little empathy
and like you know kind of become a
little bit more well-rounded character
um and maybe that's like through like
slamming his head against all these
weird time travel
you know machinations he has to kind of
come to these realizations on his own
um going off of that this is like
the sadder version um
is like because he you're right he is
like still
a dick right like he's like a dick now
or before or whatever he's still a dick
guys there he's a dick
it's the main point yeah
no because so like he's he he hasn't
learned his lessons
he doesn't care about his brother he
doesn't care about any anybody except
for his mom
oh yeah he's the only that's his only
person that he gives a [ __ ] about
so if he learns that he loses
right and that the avengers win and then
eventually he
he die like they show maybe they show
him getting killed by thanos and he's
like
that [ __ ] in this is so sad this is so
sad
but like while he's doing his adventures
or like while he's doing like the things
that he's supposed to be doing for the
tva
he could the only thing that i can think
that emotionally makes sense for him is
that he tries to go save his mom
and like change something so that she
doesn't actually die
and when thor tries to do that she
brushes him off like she like
is wise and you can tell that she kind
of is like just don't tell me about it
like whatever it's supposed to be will
be
but she tries to do that with loki but
he's loki so he's like no
that like i decided you're gonna live
and he flips up the entire
timeline because he doesn't tell anybody
that he saves his mom
and it just completely ruins everything
and again this is like over the course
that
i still like bronchitis kind of i was
like sorry
just like over the course of the entire
series so like
maybe he does save her and maybe he like
gets to secretly hang out with her
and then at the very end of the series
is like yeah he comes to the same
emotional realization that you said zach
except this time he has to just let his
mom die yeah
because like that's that's so great
because that's sort of
eric's thing of like you're doing end
game again you get to see
a scene from end game where thor's
talking to his mom and then she walks
away and walks right into loki like
that feels like the back to the future
too
of this time i mean i imagine like in
in-game you have that moment where
loki's flipping his cup in the air and
his prison cell
thor sneaks past and then right after
thor it's like the second black cat in
the neighborhood
is like big bass dude buddy i'll see you
but to save his mom that would be so
cool
it'd be yeah it's exactly what we kind
of wanted to see happen in that moment
it didn't happen
i mean i want to see all kinds of that i
want to see like you know the tva
elevator i want to see those elevator
doors open
and it's uh yeah it's uh sit well or
and it's still well and uh brock rubble
oh right after cap said hale hydra and
then loki just
it's like you have to go back and it's
like okay every single person in endgame
is also in loki it's a 38
it's like a 58 cast loki's at the battle
and he's just kind of like okay i'm
creeping around yeah
i i honestly yeah they might not get all
these actors obviously but they have
archive footage they've got these scenes
they can force gump him into anything
right like just
do a little yeah you know one one thing
that you mentioned like
him sort of sacrificing himself for his
mother or whatever or like
yeah whatever happened or saving his mom
like i don't know
how much loki has used his like i can be
anyone power yeah like you see him be
captain america
like in that avengers tower moment right
so it's like theoretically this loki can
sort of shapeshift or pretend to be
anyone and and i don't know how much
we're like
thinking like there's a version where he
pretends to be his mom and gets killed
in her place or something
there's a version where there's a
version where like
we're talking about him as quantum leap
like he could be
we could be seeing loki but he could be
db cooper he could be
these other people yeah but just
impersonating them because you know
he has that power yeah that's true
eric used the darkest timeline but we
just
actually meant emotionally darkest
it's really cloudy in this time it's the
saddest time all right well my graph
paper notebook has come up
with some points that i need to award um
all right
thank god uh i don't have sparkle books
this season i have uh some yummy gummies
that are my favorite gummies oh great
you're gonna get a little gummy lobster
for your red hulk
theory yeah for loki quantum leaping as
his mother
uh you're going to get a little yellow
sea horse
with this amazing idea of loki
having already been all these mystery
figures through history
that seems to make it all make sense in
a way so you're getting
my favorite one of these the little uh
gold uh orange
flounder clownfish i don't know and this
is a this is a cbd gummy yeah
[Music]
no or maybe that's why they wait
uh and uh marina you're gonna get a
little blue fishy
yay oh guess what on this side it turned
into dorito
uh guys this is such a like fun way to
do this i feel like i definitely got way
more out of this than having us just
read these
semi-scripted theory pitches one at a
time uh
but up to all of you watching let me
know if you like this
better uh twitter eavos is the best way
to reach me or
on our discord server uh it is open to
all channel patrons
patreon.com new rockstars uh let us know
we want to hear from you
as we uh blaze ahead in in 2021
uh we're gonna go rogue about some
new cinematic universes uh because we
can't just stay within the borders of
the mcu uh but first
i want to thank some friends who helped
us make this episode starting with our
friends at helix
sleep i have been uh losing sleep trying
to guess the plot of the loki series but
i have not been losing sleep because of
a bad mattress
i have got a personalized mattress from
the wonderful folks at helix sleep
they shipped it straight to my door with
free no contact delivery free returns
and a 100 night sleep trial
helix made a quiz that takes just two
minutes to complete and matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you
i took the quiz and i was matched with
the dusk
looks helix mattress because i wanted a
medium for a mattress with
lumbar support i love helix but you
don't need to take my word for it helix
was awarded the number one best overall
mattress pick of 2020 by gq wired
magazine
and apartment therapy just go to helix
sleep.com
rogue theory take their two-minute sleep
quiz and they will match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life
they have a 10-year warranty and you get
to try it out for 100 nights
risk-free they even pick it up for you
if you don't love it but you will love
it
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattresses and two free pillows for our
listeners at helixsleep.com
we also want to thank our friends at
expressvpn so
news flash folks you cannot watch rick
and morty fresh prince of bel air or
star trek discovery on american netflix
but i have watched them on other
countries netflix's and you
can too with expressvpn you can use
expressvpn to unlock movies and shows
that are only available in other
countries
and you don't need to even fake an
accent expressvpn lets you change your
online location so you can control where
you want sites to think you're located
you just open the app you select a
location
tap one button to connect and then
refresh the page to access
thousands of new shows and movies choose
from almost
100 different countries watch doctor who
on uk netflix or anime on japanese
netflix
and it's not just netflix folks this
works with any streaming service
hulu bbc iplayer youtube stream in
hd with no buffering or lag it's
compatible with phones laptops smart tvs
and all your other
devices not only does it let you change
your location
it also encrypts your data so it lets
you surf the web safely and anonymously
as we all should be able to do go to
expressvpn.com
rogue to get an extra three months of
expressvpn for free expressvpn.com
rogue imagine what tommy would do with
all that privacy i know
and lastly uh our good friends at blue
chew this episode was also sponsored by
blue chew guys
you remember those days when you were
always ready to go
now you can get back that extra
confidence in bed from our friends at
bluechew.com that's blue like the color
blue
bluetooth brings you the first chewable
with the same
fda approved active ingredients as
viagra and cialis
you could take them anytime day or night
so you can be ready whenever an
opportunity
arises blue chew is prescribed online by
licensed physicians so you don't
have to go to the doctor's office or
wait in line at the pharmacy and it
ships right to your door
in a discreet package but as we know
from tommy he doesn't want to be
discreet he wants it to howl like one of
those
harry potter howler messages
thank you
um so blue chew is made in the usa and
since bluetooth prepares and ships
direct they are cheaper than a pharmacy
and no awkwardness no leaving the house
no
little snickering from the pharmacist
when they pass you those pills
right now we've got a special deal for
our listeners visit pluto.com
and get your first shipment free when
you use our special promo code
rogue just pay five dollars shipping
again that's b-l-u-e
chew dot com promo code rogue to try for
free
bluetooth is a better cheaper choice and
remember when you support our sponsors
you help make this show possible so
please
be sure to use our promo code
roguebluechew.com
get a boner and keep us alive for
another month
i know that's where i go to get my phone
right it's the best it is
the best you you love a bargain and you
love it
it's a great intersection of those
things yeah yeah
uh all right guys we gotta move on uh
i've been curious to talk about this
topic with a bunch of nerds you guys
seem like the perfect panel to do this
um because i think we should move beyond
the mcu to talk about some cinematic
universes that should exist
of course we also have the star wars
universe the canon of which seems to
change on a dime every episode
there's the dc eu which i don't think
ever had continuity to begin with
the harry potter universe that keeps
changing mcgonagall's
age and birth year uh or just says she's
always been alive
that'd be a fun theory there's uh the
wonderful dark universe starring
tom cruise in the mummy that lasted one
whole movie
yep i saw that i paid money to see that
so did i and let me tell you i was like
so they're gonna make a dr
jekyll movie yeah i don't know if this
is hurting
yeah yeah but everyone's trying to cash
in on this
and now we're starting to see some crazy
ideas for cinematic universes there's
been some talk of like a hanna-barbera
film universe
there's last year's scoob pretty good
movie yeah um
they're possibly in a universe with like
yogi bear or huckleberry hound
uh the sonic director uh i paid money to
see that one
uh
killing everything he passes yeah it's
so sad the
sonic director wanted to expand the
cinematic universe of sonic and it seems
like there's gonna be a sequel that's
gonna
feature knuckles and tails uh there have
even been
calls folks i believe on this channel uh
some guests have said they want to see a
nintendo cinematic universe
we do detective pikachu uh
and pokemon is one of the most valuable
profitable brands
in the world history yeah so uh
yeah let's get let's get with it i i
heard about this nintendo one too
and it might have been on like a viral
tweet storm or something or someone
put together a really interesting
version of it and i remember the like
end game
was a smash brothers movie which i
thought was really interesting
like that is kind of what they have set
up in the universe like i think nintendo
would work
this is gonna be like when twitter came
up with the idea for ocean's eight
like they were like we should have
rihanna be a hacker and
sandra bullock be the the mastermind and
the internet
came up with it and then studios were
like okay and then they did it
the studios are like wait we're doing
the calculations that might
work we don't pay you for your idea and
we make a kajillion dollars
yes yeah yeah yeah i know nintendo's
really
precious with their ip after the like
mario movies and stuff
but i think it'd be a fun swing yeah
like a zelda movie and a mario movie and
all this stuff and then it ends up in
some team up i think that could be fun
yeah yeah are there other new cu's that
you guys
think we deserve and are entitled to so
i have been saying
forever there should be a rom-com
cinematic universe
what oh where and i don't know what
movies go in it
but like imagine you see like three you
kind of do it like
uh the split movie you like the the
shyamalan verse
oh yeah i don't know they're connected
but it's like imagine three rom-coms and
at the end of the third one they're like
the side character from the first one is
marrying a side character from the
second one
wedding movie and it's like big like
team-up wedding movie and i've always
been like this i know it's like a joke
but i'm like people like rom-coms and
then i would just
watch it for easter for just watching
eric voss break down a rom-com
universe would be there to totally break
that down you know
it's already ready to do you have love
actually which is like eight movies
one of those characters with one of the
story lines of like new year's eve
and then yeah yeah yeah jennifer lopez's
uh the wedding planner
is also somehow uh woven in and
yeah with my best friend i always
thought that that would be great and you
know what a lot of these cinematic
universes we're playing to the boys
you know what and it's great that's
right to play to the ladies
thank you sean that's right
i mean bravo and and he may have already
been doing this with like the desperate
house
with the real housewives universe of
like
you know just just make this into a
movie
and you'll have a universe of real
people real people
i just think you have weddings and
funerals and all sorts of team-ups to do
well i love it too because like
obviously there's some actors that have
made so many rom-coms like
you're you're jennifer lopez's or reese
witherspoon's or whoever
and like they have to pick which of
their characters exists in the same like
new york like she can't be both made in
manhattan and the wedding planner
but here's the thing zach i don't know
if you know but after
the incident there is a rom-com
multiverse so
jennifer lopez can exist in multiple
timelines
the uh what's the the who's the actress
from ten things i hate about you
julius childs julia so julia stiles
is the girl from 10 things i hate about
you but she's also the girl from step up
or no it saved the last time
the last dance yes of course she is
because she already was in our minds
yeah yeah yeah so combine those and also
the born identity or whatever jason
bourne movie she
does well and i think matthew
mcconaughey would exist in all these but
he's just glued to a wall that he's
leaning on
yeah yeah he's walked to the watcher and
he's like
i see all these romantic stories come
and go and then
i love it building to an avengers style
thing
where it's like meg ryan pete hudson
could you imagine though i mean i
actually felt like i
i have been in a meeting and been like
rom-com cinematic
universe i've almost been left out of
the meeting but i do think like if you
had a version of end game that was like
it's just gonna be like first wives club
with 50 of your favorite
i don't know yeah the first first one of
the clubs is first wives club
is great and that [ __ ] holds up
it does it holds up things have changed
on this channel now because we're only
talking around
it's so good it's still funny that [ __ ]
is still funny well
rom-com's like the one uh genre that's
not really connected to each other
because horror
like i mean freddie versus jason alien
vs predator those characters pop up in
each other's movies all the time yes
it would be fun to see honestly i feel
like you could do more of that in the
horror genre like i i thought freddie
versus jason and those kind of thing
like predator alien versus predator are
really fun like um
well since you brought it up um
i did not invent this this has been this
was created by
the interwebs um but if
blade and twilight ever mixed
then you just see blade
eviscerate all the the vampires
from the twilight series and it would be
so satisfying because he would use
profanity
yeah and he would just go into high
schools like he was like the high school
would be going on and he would just
break into a high school in the middle
of class and
cut off edward collins head and you
would be rooting for him
because he would be right i love that
marina he should be going to high school
it should be a teenage blade
and his story he's like figuring out his
day walker abilities at the same time
having to kill
the twilight oh it's so good
that would be really really fun i mean
all vampires and players should be
connected in the uh cinematic universe
of their own
people they already have the same rules
yeah yeah oh that'd be so great
i i had a very different idea for this
eric i love both of those ideas but like
i i was thinking about like maybe like a
standalone movie
that you would not expect to be part of
an expanded universe okay so
there was of course the the 90s classic
space jam oh
we are getting a a remake a soft reboot
or whatever stirring lebron james
everything's supposed to come out like
remix if you want yeah but i want
i want a universe okay because like you
can give me that format
x real human athlete versus a monster or
an alien
i will take that all day oh my god i
want to see
i want to see like the the new york jets
have to fight their way out of a space
prison right or i want to see
like you know the the u.s women's
national soccer team have to like
kick the heads off of a thousand aliens
or something like that like is one of
them
has to coach he has to coach her like
daffy duck becomes like ted lasso
but really like with looney tunes and
like all
real human professional athletes you
have two universes colliding and then
you also add in like aliens or monsters
or something like that yeah and then you
do the olympics as the big team up movie
right
yes dude i would watch that
oh that is i think the the only
cinematic universe that i have in my
brain that i really want to exist
is the snl cinematic universe
and if they did like a wayne's world
like wayne stock 30-year reunion with
like the roxbury guys are there and the
blues brothers are there yeah and
everybody's there
but then you find out that wayne and
garth are actually
evil and the person coming to take them
down in the parking lot is mcgruber
himself
in mcgruber versus wayne's world which i
think would be
really fun and then post credit scene
post credit scene after they've defeated
uh
wayne and garth you cut up to space
into a spaceship to a cone head who says
i'll do it myself and then he's the
thanos of the snl
cinematic universe you got to get all
the characters from snl you get
astronaut jones
you get all your favorites and then you
bring them into the world to defeat the
coneheads
that is the cinematic universe i was on
the sean i'm not gonna lie i was on the
fence until you said conan's and that i
was like yes
on board gotta remember that's the
easiest i'm in
sean has also pitched this exact thing
at a meeting
these meetings don't go that well
peacock is like no we'd prefer a less
interesting
peacock can not afford to be turning
down ideas
they need this kind of content they need
sean they need john
all right um my little fishy gummies are
coming back
shawn you're getting a yellow sea horse
for your
snl um zach
though for bringing back the monstars it
has taken too long for a space jam
reboot or sequel
we need one of those every year uh
whoever
you know the mvp of that that super bowl
is should happen
you get oh my god you get the madden
cover and you get to do
a space jam reboot yeah but you get a
clown fish for that
zach yes it's still anyone's game
because we are moving on to our final
rogue
question uh where it is anyone's game to
come up with the craziest answer to this
at select pizza hut locations they are
celebrating the 25th anniversary
of the stuffed crust pizza by giving
away
stuffed crust but with no pizza
um so the question is just a ring it's
just a ring of crust
it's just a ring oh my god wait really
yeah it's just a stuffed ring of crust
with nothing in the middle
[Laughter]
yeah that is crazy so of course that's
real
it's a real thing uh you get your hula
hoop
of crust and cheese is that's what
they're giving away
um but you gotta pay for the pizza all
right so what is the part of a food just
a part of a food that you would like to
be
served on its own oh okay
well i have an idea yeah yeah this this
is not going to be popular
i don't think but neither is what i want
i i love
two things in my food i love fruit and i
love texture
and you know what part of a fruit has
great texture the peel
oh my god just an apple peel
yeah just like the long windy no
i don't need any of the meat of the
apple just give me that oh
yeah you were right we were not going to
be on yeah
zach i feel like would be a very good
you know back in the 30s when guys used
to like have sticks and they'd tie a
bundle
on the end and they would like live on
the train track yeah
like you would be like a very efficient
and resilient
like you'd be like pass me that um
[Laughter]
zack
because i will eat it
that's not a bad that should be an snl
that's so funny
um i think the food um the food that i
would serve on its own is also kind of
gross but just maybe like fried chicken
skin
oh oh that's so funny as a kid
let's get off and just eat it you know
that's good
get me a bowl of fried chicken skin john
do you want another
like like a bag of chips but every chip
is just like a little piece
i would eat that shawn do you know that
um
this is real in texas
there is a in texas at a like a
county fair of some kind there's a thing
called fried
fried and this is real where they
take they collect like the pieces of
fried
chicken skin fried whatever that fall
off or like there's always stuff that
that
falls off they take all of that from all
the different things that were fried
and they put it in a bowl and then they
deep fry that
and then they serve it to people i love
the like drippings of from the bottom of
the face
you can deep fry fries called it's
called deep fried fried and i can't
believe that it exists but it probably
tastes so good
it's yeah
um mine's also gonna be pretty unpopular
but anybody who
like even sometimes follows me on
twitter knows that i hate
the trend of like when you make a
cupcake you put like twice the [ __ ]
frosting
to the ratio of cupcake and i can't it
doesn't make any sense to me so
just knock off the frosting and give me
a piece of cake i will eat dry ass cake
wow so normally you hear you hear the
opposite
right like they want the tops of those
no no
no because i don't know too much i don't
like it
and i would rather eat dry ass cake than
be served too much goddamn frosting
cupcake bottom is another hobo he's
hanging out with uh
anybody got any bottoms i'll eat it
you eating the bottom of that bread
cupcake but i'll go anywhere oh
yeah yeah i want cupcake bottom and
peely zach to fall in love
maybe survive anything survive any
relationship
quarrels and any apocalypse or this is
how you get the rom-com cinematic
universe going you get these
funny characters to get married and now
we're all going
yeah yeah well for making
that uh third beat connection there's
sean and and
honestly for skin for deep fried skin
that would be the one
that's good i get another yummy yummy
making you uh the winner of this week's
now to have won a conversation is it
feels
feels good you know well to those of us
who have mostly lost
uh it's an honor guys it's such a
pleasure to be here i'm such a huge fan
of new rock stars so to even be
chopping it up with you guys oh it's so
funny and totally our pleasure
and uh to all of our guests uh to sean
of course
to zach to marina thank you for joining
us this week on
rogue theory uh i i love seeing i miss
you guys all break it's so nice to be
back
uh and i'm really excited for what's to
come on this show uh
we actually have stuff to talk about in
2021
we don't have to be like oh we heard a
rumor shia labeouf's going to be playing
a rock
so here's four theories on it none of
that anymore
um well thank you to all of you for
watching uh you can support our channel
by checking out one of our many great
merch options at newrockstarsmerch.com
uh you can follow
all three of our hosts on their
respective social media
platforms you can follow me at ea boss
follow new rockstars subscribe here on
youtube
and uh if you aren't already subscribe
to the rogue theory podcast feed as well
uh give us a nice rating review if you
don't mind it really does help uh
and we will see you next week happy new
year everyone see you next time happy
new year
[Music]
you